la réaction maintenant du secrétaire
d'état chargée des droits de la femme
madame andrée bonsoir alors leur
retraite cette pilule abortive
comment réagissent et écoutez je viens
de l'apprendre à l'instant je suis un
peu étonné de voir que une fois de plus
les phénomènes d'intolérance se
manifeste d'une façon qui est pas
différente de certaines autres mais
c'est extrêmement dommage pour les
femmes et pour la liberté qu'on a avec
son corps et avec la facilité ou la
difficulté d'avoir un enfant la
législation sur la contraception reste
bien sûr en vigueur mais c'est quand
même un recul
oui je considère cette en recul et je
pense que nous serons obligés d'en
parler à certains niveaux dans notre
pays parce que ça paraît très étonnant
puisque médicalement apparemment il n'y
avait pas de problème particulier je
trouve tout à fait dommage et je
comprends mal comment on arrive à des
extrêmes de cette nature et comment ces
pressions font de cette façon là à
l'amendé vous avez été chargé par le
premier ministre de poursuivre le
dialogue avec les infirmières qui vont à
nouveau manifester demain alors ce que
vous avez en tête des mesures concrètes
le premier ministre m'a confié une
mission qui est effectivement une
mission de dialogue d'écouté qu'il a
qualifié de longue durée et de terrain
c'est à dire qu'il m'a demandé d'aller
dans les hôpitaux et de travailler au
plus près sur le territoire de notre
pays pour voir quel est le phénomène
salaires le phénomène par salaires
seulement en plus ça n'est pas tout à
fait mon rôle mais comment le fait
d'être femme pose un problème
particulier et j'ai une mission de
longue haleine en fait donc je crois
qu'il faut la construire avec la
patience qu'elle mérite
alors ce matin au conseil des ministres
vous avez présenté trois projets pour
mieux insérer les femmes dans la vie
économique et aussi dans la vie civique
on va en parler dans un instant mais
d'abord votre réaction à cet arrêt de la
cour européenne de justice selon la cour
la france n'observe pas là juste égalité
hommes femmes dans le travail
paradoxe elle considère que ce sont les
hommes qui sont défavorisés par
certaines mesures dont bénéficient en
france les femmes qui travaillent
véronique auger
halte au féminisme en france elles ont
droit à une pause et pas eux mêmes
inégalités entre les dactylos hommes et
les femmes au troisième enfant
les femmes peuvent prendre leur retraite
plus tôt et pas les zones elles ont
droit à des congés pour soigner leur
progéniture et pas injuste et surtout
non conformes à la législation
européenne
il va falloir changer cela les
dispositions cache sexe pourrait suffire
du genre le faire ou la mère de trois
enfants peut prendre sa retraite plus
tôt
cette mise au point de se faire très
vite sinon les avantages risque vu
disparaître pour tout le monde qu'on
peut craindre tout en espérant que ça
n'arrivera pas c'est que des chefs
d'entreprise qui ont des textes
conventionnels s'appuient sur la
décision de la cour de justice
européenne pour supprimer comme illégaux
ou comme reconnu illégaux des avantages
spécifiques aux femmes
malgré l'urgence un flottement est à
craindre en effet qui va changer ses
textes les partenaires sociaux par la
négociation collective ou bien le
gouvernement par la loi alors justement
va la vendre et ce qu'on va devoir
revenir sur ces dispositions spécifiques
qui favorisait les femmes au travail
en théorie elle les favoriser en
pratique que ça tombe particulièrement
mal parce que j'étais en train de
repartir avec un projet de réseau
d'entreprise qui pouvait donner quelques
chances complémentaire aux femmes
donc je crois que je vais attendre la
décision officielle et prendre contact
avec mon collègue du travail parce que
pour ma part je ne suis pas prête à
abandonner l'idée de du plus pour les
femmes du positif pour les femmes et
déjà s'annonce toutes les modifications
que l'harmonisation des règles
européenne va va imposer aussi en france
oui mais on peut peut-être penser que
les européens comme les français ont
peut-être du mal à admettre l'égalité
professionnelle des femmes il faudra
bien en parler aussi au niveau de
l'europe avec les autres membres des
gouvernants
mes collègues quand il y en a alors
madame andrée je crois qu'il y a quatre
femmes ministres sur sûr qu'on vient sur
48 dans ce gouvernement au caire est ce
que c'était serris démocratie cela j'en
ai oublié devant fin sur 48 c'est ce que
c'était c'est notre année pas tout à
fait assez mais nous allons essayer de
faire mieux
moi je sais d'engager les femmes à
rentrer dans la vie municipale assumer
des responsabilités et à faire une
progression politique d'une nature
solide durable et j'espère que aux
élections municipales et bien les maires
hommes ou femmes mais les hommes qui
conduiront des listes vont être
intéressés par cet aspect de la présence
des femmes et de leur qualité
et ça c'est un message aux dirigeants du
parti socialiste dans cette partie dont
vous êtes manquent pas seulement du
parti socialiste c'est un message vers
les maires des communes qui savent bien
que la réalité c'est que les femmes sont
actives dans les communes et qu'elles
sont capables d'assumer leur rôle d'élu
dans de très bonnes conditions c'est un
message vers les élus et aussi vers les
partis parce qu'ils sont responsables de
la place des femmes au niveau de la
construction des listes dans les grandes
villes en particulier madame andrée
merci c'est vrai qu'il reste beaucoup à
faire au camp